there's a japanese guy as well who's
like trying to review every single
starbucks in japan oh yeah yeah i know
that guy and it's like ridiculous they
taste all the same that's what i
wondered how many what can the
difference be yeah that's like like
every mcdonald's in japan he has to
probably order the same thing from each
place though otherwise it's not a good
comparison probably but i think they
have the season
even now yeah now starbucks japan has
released a thing where every single
prefecture has its own frappuccino yeah
oh does it yeah that's such a japanese
idea it's actually really cool it's kind
of genius yeah they all look super super
unique as well like none of the flavors
look the same
i went to kyoto the other day and i had
like the kyoto frappuccino and it was
like uh it was like macho with like
caramel and some [ __ ] i'm like wow yeah
[ __ ] it if i could only have this yeah
i'll have a tokyo one sucks what's the
tokyo it's like coffee jelly and some
[ __ ] that is the very tokyo thing the
coffee shop do you like jelly yeah i
think jelly is the worst dessert like it
is by far no have you had nikon jelly i
don't give a [ __ ] it is bomb
that's the cheapest one it's the
cheapest one you feel someone needs to
take can be delicious though it doesn't
have to be expensive basically like
mattress filler i don't want to eat it
no because like
you don't just want jelly by itself
right i mean sometimes you want jelly by
itself but it's if it's like
incorporated in a dessert you don't like
it it's really [ __ ] good with a bit
of ice cream i can't stand it it's awful
i love coffee what do you like about
jelly
it just it tastes like nothing half the
time and when it does taste like
something it's like you could have made
you could have made
you could have made literally anything
else with this flavor profile and it
would have been 10 times better because
it didn't feel like a floppy mess in my
mouth
something it's just a very
light jelly
it's just a very light flavor that like
it's it's not too strong yeah a lot of
times it's just very light sometimes i
don't want a dessert that like punches
me in the fridge it's like like a
slippery and also i just don't like it
it's just lighter than like an ice cream
is it also the texture you don't like
the texture is a massive part of it okay
but i also find that so you don't like
gelatinous
no but i found that the flavors can be
replicated in any other dessert that is
just better like what like ice cream ice
cream
ice creams you need an ice cream jelly
don't taste anything like what are you
talking about jelly you could have done
ice cream coffee you know what i mean
like that would have been usually yeah
usually you get like a vanilla ice cream
with coffee jelly like that shit's great
oh no do you put just put like a porn
espresso on it i forgot you know
i'd rather that don't do this jelly [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's jelly
ice cream and jelly taste nothing alike
even if they have the same flavor
profile it's like it's like two totally
different textures i don't know i just i
i find that it's like i just don't think
you're a fan of gelatinous things yeah
no and it's also like when they do it
i'm like really couldn't afford gelato
or ice cream really
i feel like that's what's going on
yeah oh you have and if they gave me
jelly i'd be like wow i saw i saw what
you skimped on the budget
jelly you know i can make i can make 20
liters of jelly in like 10 minutes with
like 10 bucks you know i don't want the
[ __ ]
you know how hard it would be to fill a
bathtub of ice cream that shit's going
to actually taste like nothing though
like the jelly that comes out of like
higher end restaurants actually has a
lot of flavor in my opinion it's like
fruit they'll extract the juice oh god i
hate fruit jelly so much jelly's the
best it's like fruit is the best fruit
jelly is literally the best you ruined
fruit by making it into a jelly format
it's literally no there's some fruits
that are better yeah like yeah i i would
i would argue that like fruits make
better jellies than they do ice cream
yeah
actually yes yes
yes you can try its full potential the
texture of how it's changed by being
cooked
look look jelly like fruit jelly is
refreshing as [ __ ] fruit ice cream is
not refreshing a lot of the time
that's a sorbet but
ice cream doesn't know what kind of
banana strawberry banana ice cream does
not taste like bread i will take i will
take strawberry jelly over strawberry
ice cream any day
yeah what never happened good strawberry
jelly though well strawberry jelly is
normally like the cheap the chicken
jello the the jello it's only the cheap
jelly but like so strawberry ice cream
so every ice cream is normally the cheap
the cheap ice cream i don't know what
strawberry ice cream i don't oh my god
oh my god joey
this is one of my brothers this is
this one i don't like it either
but i would i would take it over jelly
strawberry ice cream i think is just
like the worst ice cream it always
tastes like strawberries yeah banana
though
banana is good but it's not that's not
the same flavor as an actual banana why
does banana lend itself so well to
everything like everything banana flavor
tastes amazing yeah i agree with that
and like everything orange tastes so
artificial in [ __ ]
no no no no no no no orange no
lauren
lolli
what's the point of me
[Laughter]
did you catch that oh it's because we
stayed in australia
[Laughter]
the lollipops right americans call them
lollipops too right yeah lollipops yeah
don't don't choose the subject sorry uh
your awareness tastes like [ __ ]
no you're wrong you're wrong i i think
like i think the orange orange desserts
taste better than bananas
oh come on
do you like moose by the way yeah i like
most
fake ice cream sometimes
we found the reason categorically right
i have not had a single dessert right
that i'm like
ice cream would just be better than this
it's not a single dessert maybe you
think ice cream is better i can find you
a dessert like apple pie apple pie is
great it's okay but i can i can find you
something better but like what what was
the thing that you said you only like
apple pie because it works well with ice
cream
anything that works well with ice cream
do you like chocolate cake i love
chocolate cake what kind of chocolate
like japanese chocolate cake oh i don't
think i've ever had japanese oh i got
like a volcano chocolate cake american
icing is sometimes icing is too heavy
you know and yeah
like cement-like gets lighter when you
microwave it
that just sounds that's the tidbit for
the day no it's so good
why would you want it
because to me a moose is just inferior
ice cream moose does chase most of the
time sometimes sometimes you just don't
want something as heavy as ice just have
freeze
which is a cream just have less ice
cream huh no even a spoon of the ice
cream
fills your mouth with the cream though
if americans saw the haagen-dazs size in
japan i think they'd cry i i cried when
i first saw it have you seen how tiny no
to me that's the perfect size yeah i
can't have any more haagen-dazs than
that yeah but i won't lie i do wish i
had the tub just so if i really didn't
have a bad day i could chow down the two
of them like does dessert's the one meal
where i'm like really picky because it
depends on what i've eaten directly
beforehand that dictates what dessert i
order right you can't just order the
same dessert every time i don't even i
don't eat desserts yeah like okay like
like like i i agree that ice cream i
think is the best dessert it's either
ice cream or cake right but i i can't
like if if i had if i like an empty
stomach i'd always go for ice cream or
cake but like
sometimes you just don't feel like that
after a really heavy meal sometimes
sometimes chocolate just seems way too
heavy and you just want something light
yeah
always
german soup or ice cream in some form
tiramisu i could have like anything and
i can be half a tiramisu after to be
fair tiramisu is my favorite cake but i
can't have it after every meal i can
have everything really it's a very heavy
it's a heavy cake is it heavy it doesn't
feel heavy at all
like it's like to me the biggest [ __ ]
lie i hear people say is like oh you
have a second stomach for dessert i'm
like [ __ ] that shit's alive [ __ ]
you just didn't enough you just didn't
eat enough main course that's it no it's
actually it's true check your mind
the way your taste buds work is that
they get sick of one flavor so when you
introduce a new flavor it makes more
room for it no that's not just not with
me that's not concrete but
[Laughter]
i watched a very informal vox video
about this and apparently yeah it's you
oh my god i want to see melee at a
buffet i can't eat as much